Now that we've got an understanding of what the User Widget is, let's take a look at Unreal's inbuilt tool for visually authoring them.
But firstly, how do we create a new widget?
Simply right-click in the content browser of your project and click Widget Blueprint under the User Interface category.
This will create a new widget, extending off of User Widget by default, as an asset in your content browser.
Opening this asset will summon the Widget Blueprint editor, and this is our authoring tool for developing UI with UMG.
We can see straight away that we've got a whole suite of menus and toolboxes to explore.
Right at the top in section 1, we've got the Common Toolbar.
This is pretty much the standard toolbar that we'd find in any of the existing tools within Unreal,
and we have access to File, Editor, Help, it's the usual suspects.
Underneath that in section 2, we've got the Toolbar.
This contains a number of common functions that we also find in the regular Blueprint editor, that being Compile, Save and Play.
Section 3 is the Editor Mode Selection.
This lets us swap between the Designer View, which is what we're currently looking at, and a more typical Blueprint graph view.
Each widget has got a Designer Front End, a Blueprint Back End, and a C++ Base under the hood,
much in the same way that an Actor Blueprint has got a viewport view instead of a Designer.
The same sort of architecture is at play here.
On the left in section 4, we've got the Palette.
This is a list of widgets that can be dragged and dropped into the Visual Designer,
and will display anything that inherits from UWidget.
This will also include any containers such as vertical and horizontal boxes, scroll boxes, overlays, borders, spaces.
It's the usual toolset for any visual UI design.
It'll also contain any user generated widgets.
So say we've got a health bar already made up, and now we're working on a Master HUD widget.
We can drag a health bar into the Master HUD widget by simply navigating to the user created category,
and selecting the widget that we'd like.
Below the Palette, we've got the Hierarchy view of section 5.
This view is a tree view of the parenting structure of the current widget,
and for ease, we can also drag directly from the Palette into the Hierarchy view,
to position new widgets exactly where we'd like them.
From there, we've got section 6, which is the Visual Designer proper.
This is a visual representation of the layout, with each visual element viable for manipulation once placed.
That can be moving it around, changing properties, deleting, resizing, or even reparenting to other widgets.
Section 7 is the Details panel, and here we can see information about the currently selected widget,
and change any of its exposed properties.
For instance, we could freely change the U texture source of an image widget.
Finally, in section 8, it's where we can author keyframed animations for widgets.
So say we want some UI to bounce onto the screen when we click a button.
This is where we'd actually author that bounce.
We'll touch on animation actually quite heavily, in more detail later on in this talk.
Just as a quick example, we can see here that we've got an image widget being dragged into the Visual Designer.
We're navigating over to the Details panel, and selecting a U texture source.
We can also see in the Hierarchy view, that it's updated to show that we've now got an image widget
as a child of the Canvas panel, which is the base container for all widgets by default.
Authoring widgets in UMG is exceptionally easy.
If we were to spawn this class and add it to the viewport,
we'd see that exact same star with the exact same offset from the top left.
As you can see, if we switch over to the Graph view instead of the Designer view,
we're dealing with the same framework that we've got right across the engine.
That being a blueprint backend to some kind of visual frontend.
This holds true for the animation graphs, the actor graphs, and now the UMG graphs.
We've got access to a series of contextual nodes to drive any logic that we may want our UI to run.